then we'll start. Okay, welcome to the
DDPS seminar everyone. Before we
introduce our invited speaker, let's go
over some rules and logistics. First,
please mute yourself during the talk.
Um, but if you have question, you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your question so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed. So uh
please watch up. Finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's it. Let me
briefly introduce our speaker today. It
is an honor to host Dr. uh Sa Kong who
is a distinguished professor of
mathematics at the Georgia Tech where
she has taught since August 2008. She
received her PhD in applied mathematics
from UCLA in 2002. Her research focuses
on advanced mathematical approaches to
image processing using variational
functional and PTE based methods for
tasks like den noising, deep learning,
inpainting and segmentation. She also
explores numerical methods and
scientific computing including data
clustering and the differential equation
identification from limited data. In
addition to her research, Professor Kong
serves as the cse coordinator from the
school of mathematics, overseeing both
the CSE stu uh PhD and MS programs and
mentoring students uh interested in
applying uh mathematical ideas to
practical challenges. Today, Professor
Kang will talk about identifying
differential equations from uh single
observations with the numerical methods,
ident. I'm sure uh we are going to hear
a wonderful talk. Now, let me um um
well, before I pass the button to uh
professor Khan, let me ask a questions.
Professor Khan, we usually do so, so
don't be surprised. some informal quest
questions before you actually give a
presentations. So today's um questions
would be if if you can share any
supernatural ability you have uh
like some supernatural hobby like not
ordinary people might have. Yeah, if you
have one, please share with us. Sorry
for the unexpected question.
Oh yes. Um now I feel like so
insignificant
of supernatural ability. Um I'm just a
normal person. Um yeah I'm just a normal
person. I try to be kind in every day.
Um and that that's all all I can say. So
Oh well well that's supernatural. I mean
I've my personally I it's very hard for
me to be kind. So thank you. Thank you.
Try try is the word. Try is the key
word. Right. Right.
Okay. All right. Stacy, it's yours. Yes.
Thank you very much. So, I would like to
thank um Dr. uh Choy for inviting me. I
am very very grateful uh to to be uh
presenting this work here today and
thank you everybody for coming um and uh
attending my talk today. I really
appreciate this. Okay. So, today I'm
going to talk about identifying
differential equations from single
observation with numerical method.
So the objective the problem setup goes
like this. Um so the initial motivation
that I had was that this was like maybe
like more than 12 years ago. I had this
idea that when we observe something very
interesting physical phenomenon um then
let's say I just happened to take a
video. I wanted to see if this from this
video it can tell us what equation that
this is. So that was the motivation that
how do we um find the information from
the single observation. This is the
motivation. Now um I do emphasize on
single observation because we may not
have a second chance to record this
phenomena again. Um and also when we
deal with the real data we need to
assume there are some noisy observation
as well. So the motivation is to find um
this equation f something like this um
from the observed data. Now this idea
has been explored for a long time. So um
this is not this is not an ex extensive
list but this is just like um the just
to give you an idea. So especially in
the biology like a lot of identification
of the system has been explored um as
early as 1969 and this is thanks to um
uh David Boltz shout out uh to uh
professor Boltz that um there are a lot
of work that looking into these kind of
dynamical system try to understand uh
from the the the observation what is
your underlying
dynamic but since we don't know anything
about the underlining equation
It is natural to assume or natural to
think what is the simple equation. So
for this reason we want to have maybe
small number of terms expressing the
equation. So naturally the sparsity gets
into this problem. So there the most
famous work in this area the recently
using the sparsity is the Cindi um in
identifying dynamical system. There are
some theoretical works and there are
some work on PTE. Um also there are some
work using the weak forms. Um in in this
relation I will mostly focus on OD and
PTE problems but this problem can be
also formulated or um in understood in
terms of interactive law. So the
agentbased method different agents there
are many different agents and how are
they going to interact and how do we
find out the information from that. So
there is some work in this direction
also some machine learning as well. So
you can kind of train the the network to
identify certain
thing. So for the today's talk um we had
number of work on this direction of
identification. So what I want to do
today is that rather than focusing on
one paper I want to give an overarching
idea of this um this uh direction. So
we've been working on many different
things. So there are certain things that
we found out what is important in these
um this ident. So we've been calling
this ident as a identification of
differential equation using uh numerical
time evolution but any kind of method um
the these are all using uh different
numerical techniques to actually find
it. So what I want to do today is that
starting from ident. So this was our
initial work. So this is going to act as
a backbone and I want to show what kind
of improvements that we have made and
what kind of things that we found out
through through this journey of
exploring this idea. So hopefully by at
the end of the talk that you will have a
good idea about what is important and
how we can do different things and what
are the differences between some of the
method that we have been proposing.
Okay. So let's start from the beginning.
As I said um I do find it to be very
important to have a single set of time
dependent data and we assume that this
data is noisy. At the beginning of this
area uh some of the earlier work put in
the noise in a different way some
interesting way but we wanted to be true
to it. So we just add the noise from the
given observation is assumed to have um
additive noise. So you have u plus an
epsilon something like that. um as I
will uh talk about this noise is very
difficult to deal with in real in this
um approach. So the denoising is very
important. So that is going to be one
part that I want you to pay attention.
Now since we don't know anything about
the underlining equation so it is it is
beneficial to have certain assumption.
So the first one assumption that we make
is that this f should be a linear
combination of some of the feature
term. So each term can be nonlinear. You
can have uxx² ux or uxx. So you can have
a nonlinear term but still it can be
represented as a linear combination is
the assumption that we make.
So these when when you have these kind
of feature term people ask this is
called uh some people call this a
dictionary. How do you choose this
dictionary? And then when we started
doing comparison you I we realized some
of the method did not use the full um
dictionary but they sort of handpicked
certain thing. So I just want to be
clear that what we want to do is we
really want to understand what is going
on without any assumption. So
systematically we gave the dictionary
for example it can have up to two
multiple of the term or up to six
multiple of the term up to two second
derivative or up to fifth derivative or
sixth derivative. So when once we make
this decision we put in all of these
term in the dictionary the and we're
going to call this to be a feature term.
So in this case this example is up to
two multiple of two second order
derivative. So these are all of the
terms that which is represented when you
allow this to be two multiple and with a
second order in the experiment that we
did up to six fifth multiple or sixth
derivative. So at the end some of the
dictionary it was 190 terms and so on
and so forth. So but we try to be
consistent without giving any bias at
the beginning just because we make this
assumption that given data u can be
represented as each column. So this term
is going to be constant term. This term
is going to be u and this u is going to
be the given data. U² you just multiply
it twice. Ux you have to approximate.
Now you have ux squar the ux is m uh
approximated and then you square it and
then uxx has to be approximated. So all
of these feature term that we put in we
have to approximate the derivative.
Now if you write it in this matrix form
that this a coefficient a1 a2 a3 a4 this
can be represented as a vector. We're
going to call this to be a coefficient
vector. Throughout this talk I'm going
to use two terminology. One is support
and one is a coefficient value. Support
meaning we assume we allow the equation
to have any of these 10 term. So if we
identify certain term to be non zero
we'll call that to be a support. So for
example if you have a burgers equation
then you will have a6 this term to be
identified. So only coefficient a6 is
going to be non zero. Everything else is
going to be zero and we will call this
to be a support and we still need to
recover the coefficient a6. So then
we'll call this to be a coefficient
value.
And you you have this term which is f *
a and b is going to be our ut. So this
is the time the way how this is dynamic
is changing in terms of time and this is
represented by b also it needs to be
approximated by some approximation
numerical approximation for that.
So this talk has no deep learning.
There's no training. And as I said,
we're just going to have one single
observation. And this work is really
about how far can we go without learning
anything um from one single observation.
So often times our time can be shorter
than some of the um other cases, but
whatever the time might be short, time
might be long, we're just doing our best
to find the best approximation.
Um okay so let's start from the ident
this is because to give a backbone of
this um this idea from the given
discrete data um this is the u this is
the only thing which is given but this
is time changing in time as well as the
space is all
given we construct the feature matrix as
I just explained and then we have a
vector B which is UT all of the
derivative approximation in each column
for this work we did eno scheme so enact
because we wanted to guarantee up to
second order derivative will be second
order um accurate so we use enofi for
each column whenever you have a
derivative and then we needed to den
noiseise this denoising is really
imposing a lot of challenge to this
process so we will pay attention to that
in this particular work we use moving
average le
square after that as a first work we
tried the convention thing meaning that
we add the L1 minimization and we use
lasso. So the coefficient itself is
supposed to be sparse that is the
underlining assumption. However, we
found that that was not enough. So
throughout this process that you will
see we do use sparsity but often times
the sparsity is not enough because of
the noise because we add noise because
of different variation. So we do add a
second step of model selection. In this
case we use what is called time
evolution error. So among this result
we're picking the one and then after we
pick the support. So we identify the
support then we identify the coefficient
by le square because we already know
which terms are non zero. So only
letting those term uh to find the value
then we do the le square. Now we have a
very
consistency. First one important thing
is the least linear system. How do you
set up a linear system is important and
how do you do a den noising is
important. After that setup is done we
are going to do the support
identification. This is the actual
equation
identification. And after the support
the equation itself form of the equation
is identified. Then we're going to find
the coefficient by just le square fit
the given data. you just fit it. So this
is consistently you're going to see this
uh three things which is um the main uh
backbone of
this in ident we use what is called
moving average le square because at the
beginning we wanted to try different
type of
denoising we tried le square fitting we
tried moving average but moving average
le square seems to be the best I know a
lot of denoising method because my my
background is in imaging but we didn't
use any of this method but we use the
method which we can guarantee the order
of recovery. So in this work that we
assume uh we prove that if it is a third
order approximation of the smooth
function then the uh moving average le
square will keep the same order of
approximation. So but you can generalize
this to higher order. So we wanted to
have a order guarantee of the den
noising. So that's why we use a moving
average. So this is an effect.
Let's say you're given uh Burger's
equation and then this is time dependent
and you have a noise. You have 8% noise.
Now if you use L1 the lasso that we use
these are the coefficient that comes out
which is non zero. This is burger's
equation. So the correct term should be
ux but that term is actually zero. So
there are three terms which is
identified which is completely not
related to the underlying dynamic that
we're looking for. So there's no
denoising then it's bad. So it's very
difficult to do. So when you apply the
denoising we use the moving average le
square. So you do a den noising on the
data itself just denoising once. Then
when you do the uh L1 minimization you
will have these three terms coming
up. If you do the lasso in this
particular case the coefficient of uux
is the biggest. So you might simply
think okay how about you threshold it
but it doesn't it's not as simple as
that. Sometimes this coefficient that
this is identified to be non zero can be
very high. So we find that to be not
enough to actually just have consider
the threshold because the result will be
dependent on what kind of threshold that
we are
enforcing. So this is when the time
evolution error comes in. So what we did
is that okay we take all nonzero one u
and u ux so you have three terms from
the three terms consider all of the pds
that you can make with these three term
ut equals to constant ut is equal to u
ut is equal to ux ux ut is equal to
constant plus u constant plus u ux u uu
and then constant u u ux so there are
seven equation that you can consider by
Having these three non-zero term we
consider everything. So now what do we
do from here among these three equation
you find the coefficient by le square.
In this case we didn't do anything
special. You first find the coefficient
for each equation. We find the best one.
How do we find it? We just take the
initial condition. You're given a data
which is time dependent. So you just
take the initial condition and then plug
it in. you regenerate numerically
regenerate uh the evolution for all
these seven equation. So from the
initial condition and then you generate
with a small delta t and then see at the
end it matches up which matches up the
best we pick to be the best one. This is
really a fundamental of the numerical
convergence basically. So you evolve
with a smaller delta t is very
important. So among the seven you check
it just at the very end at the beginning
at the end and then whatever gives you
the smallest error we pick it. So this
is how we pick the burgers equation for
this
case. So there the reason for having a t
is because L1 minimization is not
enough. Usually it gives you zero
coefficients for non-zero one and non
zero zero. It should be zero but it
gives non zero and then it depends on
the thresholding. it depends on the
lambda and so on and so forth. So this
is why we um uh add the model selection
as a time evolution. But I will show you
many different cases for that. Okay. So
many different there's a two fundamental
idea behind the time evolution error.
One is a numerical convergence. This is
what we teach right in the numerical
PTE. If you have a converging converging
method then it has to be stable and
consistent. So if your delta t gets
smaller at least it needs to get closer
to the equation. So this is why we
evolve we regenerate the data with
smaller delta t and see if it actually
matches up. Another reason is that in
nonlinear PTE you cannot say go to each
term and say do you exist or not? Are
you yes or no? Yes or no. You cannot do
that. In nonlinear PD you have to work
as a set. So you need to really work as
a set as here like u constant and u u
and ux you have to consider this as a
set and see if this actually matches up
but this time evolution error is very
slow as you can imagine right the
complexity so you give an initial
condition and you have to wait until
evolve all the way to the end so this is
red is one example green is another one
we picked a small one but we do better
than that so this is being inspire ired
by the shooting method. You have
shooting method multi-shooting. So we do
multi- time evolution. So in the robot
side then that we move from this and
then we do multi-shooting. So in
multiple location you evolve the same
equation and then add these error. So
idea is fundamentally same and then
similar to also similar to
multi-shooting. So then your time
evolution has to be done in a small
time. So it is it gives you a saving and
also you can do this in parallel. So
this is one one model
selection. So in the original ident so
this is what we show that having a den
noising gives much better error than no
denoising as the noise level increases
that it is significantly better to have
a denoising
method in this equation is burgers
equation. Now burger's equation looks
like oh okay this looks pretty well it
works pretty well up to 30% noise
however in this equation if you add a
little bit of diffusion like a viscos
the burgers equation it starts to uh not
work as well this can only handle up to
0.05 5 or something like
this. So the reason is this. So in this
paper that we have an error analysis
showing the difficulty of this problem.
So this is the sensitivity to the
measurement noise. So what basically
says is that if the underlining equation
is higher order, it is that much
difficult to find it is because of the
denominator. So if your underlying
equation has fourth order fifth order
derivative it is that much difficult to
find especially because we are assuming
there are noise to that. So this this
shows the
difficulty. So how do you move forward
from this? So we learned something from
this. So now we move
forward in the previous ident that we
found out denoising is important now but
if you look at the denoising this is the
effect.
This is the initial uh u and then you
have a very very small noise. Now you
approximate this is a derivative then
the derivative noise gets emphasized. If
you consider the second derivative the
noise get even more emphasized. So we
developed the better denoising method.
So what is called stdd successive den
noiseise
differentiation. So every time we do a
differentiation we're going to do a den
noiseise one more time. So given the u
you denoise it and then you have a
derivative. So derivative approximation
you denoise it one more time. If you
have k you do that. So you smooth
differentiation smooth differentiation
and so on.
This sounds really really crazy right
but there is we can show that under the
assumption some small assumption the
smaller assumption is that polomial has
to be degree s and then the method of
approximation should be accuracy at
least s minus one then we can recover
this to be s minus one. So it sounds
really crazy but successfully doing has
a benefit to that. So in the robust
ident so we made two improvement one is
a den noising so when we're making a
feature matrix we den noiseise it better
and then the sparsity we improved
also what we found out is that in L1
minimization that there are terms that
which comes out with a very small
coefficient we can which we cannot
control so rather than going into that
route we just gave them. So what we did
is okay K is equal to one find the best
column to represent this this given data
k is equal to two find the two best
column to represent this k is equal to 3
k is equal to 4 k is equal to 5 you we
do all of this for each k but the
subspace pursue requires the sub sparity
so we have to do everything k is equal
to 1 k is equal to 2 k is equal to 3 k
is equal to 4 and so on so now among
this now we need to choose the best one
so again the model selection. So we use
the sparsity but we accompany this by
model se selection. So how do we do it?
In this case we did the multi-shooting
as I explained
earlier. However we found out the soft
space pursuit itself is more stable but
even cross validation was good enough.
So what is cross validation? Cross
validation is that let's say that much
data is given. So you cut it in half. It
doesn't have to be half. We can cut by
alpha. we also analyzed in the paper you
let's say roughly cut in half and then
use this to find the coefficient and use
that result to fit right so you just
cross validate what is the best one and
in this case then you can choose among
all different K you choose the best one
so once you choose it that's a support
and from the support you find the
coefficient by le square it's the same
so I hope you see the trend right now so
linear system with a den noising is
important
And then after that you use a sparity
but you need to use the sparcity in a
correct way and then after that you do
the coefficient identification by the
square
fit. So this is some of the results. So
in the robust ident so you can handle
some discontinuity. Discontin is because
we use the eno the eno scheme. So you
can handle the uh discontinuity uh the
noise with 10% noise or 30% noise but
still it can identify. So here 10% noise
this is the equation which is identified
30% noises is identified. The true
equation is UT is equal tox² on top here
and then these are the recovery with a
30%
noise. We can do this with a burgers
equation with diffusion because this can
handle up to 5% noise and maybe a little
bit more but this comparison was
meaningful for us because in ident that
we could only do 0.05 but just because
of this STD and using the the cross
validation that we were able to get to
this we can also enter third third uh
order derivative. Now from here how do
we go forward? So the next part is the
weak weak
ident around this time actually there
were multiple work that which is using
the weak form. So okay so we decided to
try this as well. Yes. Oh thank you
David. Um so yes so the weak form now
one of the best part of the weak form
the difference between the ident robots
ident and the weak ident is that it's a
differential form versus integration
form. So the weak form is a numerical
integration. Another beautiful part of
this weak form is the test function. If
you use the good test function, this can
suck up a lot of the difficulty from the
differential equation. So that is
important. Now from here we can do even
further. So I talked about how to find
the sparsity and modal selection. We
improve that even. So we improve this
with a narrow fit with a trimming and
then we can also do the coefficient
identification even better.
Okay. Okay.
So going back to the consistent scheme
now this is the linear system is
important and we we set it up as a weak
form and the noising is coming from the
weak form. Now the sparsity is
important. So we use SP in this case by
using the narrow fit and trimming which
I will explain. You can improve upon
this result and then we can get the
coefficient also uh to be
improved in the weak
ident. Number one the weak
form. Now weak form is great because of
this. The weak form is great because of
the integration by part. You're setting
up the equation. The differential
equation is given. You multiply this by
a test function and take an integral.
And then after you take an integral, the
key point is that you need to do an
integration by part such that all of the
derivative needs to move to the test
function.
Because of this, in order to truly
benefit from the equation, truly benefit
from the weak form, your equation has to
be a certain form. So it needs to be u
to the alpha beta power to the alpha
derivative. Then you can really benefit
from the weak form because all of the
integration part part will take up uh in
the the test function because test
function is the one that we give. So we
can give a very nice uh test function
which is smooth. So that is one
benefit. Um so yes shout out to uh uh
messenger and both um on the test
function because when when we started
looking into this weak form we tried
many many things we tried different test
function and so on but this text test
function really works very well. So the
way that we understood is that there is
a denoising effect because you're trying
to match the polomial the the shape of a
Gaussian. One thing we found out is
chopping is not good. Actually the
surprisingly chopping is not good. You
need to sort of suppress it in a right
way such that you will achieve the
noising at the same time. So the there
are certain things that you can look
into in this test function. So you don't
need to compute the derivative and then
the approximation of the numerical
integration can be higher order by
whatever the method that you use. That's
the first
thing. Second thing I want to mention is
that what we found out is that this
feature matrix where this is W because
it's a weak form. The feature matrix
needs to be sort of well conditioned. So
what the another thing we found out is
that each column needs to be normalized
in a proper way. So in fact in this
paper we introduced two different kinds
of normalization. One is the error
normalization that which is presented
here and one is also a column
normalization which is needed for the
SP. So how do you normalize a column? Uh
this is also important. So in this
particular case what what we are
mentioning here is
that depending on the feature term your
error might be different. So we wanted
to balance it if you have like a higher
order or not we wanted to balance. So
this is the the term that which actually
we can explicitly compute the error term
the leading coefficient so that we error
normalize each normal uh column for
that. So this is the weak ident. So you
have a weak form the feature matrix and
B which is UT and you're trying to do
the SP okay so you do the subspace
pursuit now here we added what is called
narrow fit and trimming okay narrow fit
and trimming what is narrow
fit up to now all of the coefficient
recovery we're doing we've been using
the whole le square from the given data
that's all we did but actually we can do
better so what we found out is that
given a data there are regions there are
more dynamics than the other. So for
example this is the image there's sort
of flattish and then there are some
places that there are some dynamic these
places doesn't really contribute too
much but you cannot get rid of
everything. So what we do is that we
identify the high dynamic region which
is given by the high dynamic of u ux we
also experiment with a different feature
but in order to identify the dynamic how
much it is changing u needs to change
right and then ux needs to change so
this is why we find u and ux to be the
most meaningful to indicate what's the
high
dynamic so we just find the region that
which there are a lot of variation so
this yellow is the part that we're going
to use. So given data is this much but
only the yellow we fit. So the fitting
of the lean square even gets smaller now
because we are only doing a smaller
region and surprisingly the coefficient
recovery gets better. So the high
dynamic we found it to be
important. Now trimming as I said from
the beginning because we're using the SP
softspace pursuit K is equal to 1, K is
equal to 2, K is equal to 3, K is equal
to 4. All of this needs to be computed
but some of them you don't need because
when we're doing le square the more
terms you have better approximation is
going to be but that more term may not
be meaningful. So how do you do it? So
we trim some of them which is not
important remove it. How do we know what
is important or not? How does it
influence our UT is the key. You have a
column of UT, but you added a new
column, but this one contributes really
minimally to the dynamic UT. We get rid
of it. So this threshold was just 0.05.
And then for each sparity level, we're
computing. But as you can see, quickly
it converges to the right one. So even
if we need this, we allow to find
sparity up to 40 because this um
dictionary was likeund and something. So
we ran up to sparity 40 that's because
of that. So we have a really really
large day
uh
um dictionary but still it kind of
removes it. So you don't need that. So
it quickly converges to what you need.
So this just shows a com comparison. So
um in the PTE we try these equations um
like uh 2D equations and then double
derivative and so on. fourth derivative
um and it it works well when you don't
have noise lot of methods actually work
well so we get very similar result this
is the true one and these are uh the
results we did compare to ident also the
SP um the robust ident as well and weak
ident is much better now this is the
coefficient error actual coefficient
that it works about now this is noise
level one meaning 100% we add 100%
noise. So as the noise level increases
then you can show some benefit. So then
you can show we systematically did it.
So for each different noise level we ran
like 50 times and then show the variance
of it. So this is the noise level and so
on and then this is the true positive
and then the uh the the false positive
and so on. And this WPD was the weekindi
weak PTE.
um and this is also um two variable with
the second order derivative and so on.
Then this is the equation that we
recover. It looks quite messy but the
true value is one and this is 0.99. This
value is one 0.98. So it's actually
quite close. So we represent the
coefficient error is L2 norm and is the
difference is 0.03. So that's what I
want to show. We also applied this to
OD. Um most of the work we did at some
PTE but we also tried with a PD. For
this experiment we found out that this
doesn't have any derivative terms
necessarily. So we didn't find this to
be particularly difficult and we chose
these to compare with other method.
So the red is the given data while the
blue black is the true data. So from the
bl the red dots the noisy data that we
were able to recover green. So that's
the green that we recovered from the red
data that we recovered the green and
these are the showing the coefficient
error like which is um shows a good uh
recovery. Um okay so uh this is also
comparing with the OD. So this is weak
ident this is the weak Cindy OD and we
did compare to Cindy because this was uh
ODI. So the dynamical system that we did
compare so there's a this is the
proposed method with an error with a
small variation but there sometimes you
have a lot of variation. This is because
we ran like 50 time for each noise level
with a each time running that you will
have a different noise. So this is the
reason. So this is sort of a
representative results
for okay. So how do we move forward from
this? So now this work is on for ident.
So now for ident is because in the weak
ident to do the test function we
actually have to sol solve it in the
forident at the beginning but then you
come back to physical domain. So here we
said okay how about we continue in the
forier domain can we find out something
now here like if you go to the forier
domain you can do it but it turns out
this is much difficult much more this is
more difficult than the solving things
in the physical domain the reason is the
value of the response is all over the
place so some response is really big
some response is really small so it's a
very big variation so we find that
important to reduce the domain. So now
the infor space what it boils down to is
to chop the domain and then only use the
meaningful information to do it. So that
is a one thing. So more one meaningful
region and we also use a softspace
pursue but also use the core region. I
will show you uh in uh the example and
then we also find what is the best one.
We also use the grip trimming and then
also find the best data to fit. So the
lean square fit even we are moving
forward a little bit from
that. So this is just to show the
consistency of the the work that we are
doing. So linear system in this case in
the 4A domain denoising is done in a 4A
domain by the partition domain
partition. The sparsity is important
that you identify this and also we use
the frequency domain partition and then
find the best result. So there's three
steps that it is
consistent. One thing I can say is that
the error analysis the one thing is
interesting is the error analysis. In
the initial at the be very beginning I
showed you the ident had an error term
like this that you have an epsilon the
noise can get emphasized if the
underlining p uh equation is high order
but if you use a weak then it become a
linear form this is the same in the
forier as well. So when you use the
integration form or um so you have sort
of like a kernelbased method then the
error can be small it can be less
dependent on the the order of the
underlining equation. So that's what
we're showing just to briefly
illustrate. Uh so this is SP so the soft
space pursuit with K is equal to one
they identify the one best column at K
is equal to two they identify two best
column and then three now you go to
fourth one so let's say K is equal to
four you find four terms now you found
the four term but there is a score that
we compute one of them is so small so we
cut it yeah you're not so important and
then you update this becomes the same as
the sparity 31 one and then if you go to
five the same two of the one is not as
important so then it goes back to three.
So even if we allow to find uh sparsity
up to 10 or 20 the trimming really helps
to kind of give the meaningful one by
removing the uh unimportant
things. Now this is showing the effect
of the using the frequency domain.
So the frequency domain is this large.
But if you follow the theory of the for
analysis, if the underlining data itself
has a certain smoothness, then the
coefficient has to die down in a certain
speed. If you consider that region, that
is this red one. So this red one is the
only meaningful region that you can
guarantee from theory. So this red
region is uh zoomed in here. So this is
the only meaningful region even within
the meaningful region for each each
feature term some might be noisy some
might be not as important. So we even
partition that and only use these region
and you can get the coefficient recovery
to be really accurate in that way. So
this is the coefficient right the
coefficient value recovery improvement.
One of the best part of the fora ident
is for ident can be comparable to weak
ident um as well as weeks inde. So the
if you look at the paper that we have a
comparison one of the good thing about
the for ident is that if your initial
condition or given data has many many
modes even if you have really high level
of noise that it can still be better
than other methods. So that is one of
the benefit in some level I guess it
makes sense because you're using in the
4A domain.
Just to quickly summarize what I talked
about up to now is this given a single
set of time dependent data whatever it
is it may not be enough data but we will
do our best to give you something
meaningful. So single set of time
dependent data which is noisy and uh
noise and high order derivative higher
order underlying dynamics makes it
difficult. However, if you set up the
linear system in a good way, you do the
denoising in a sophisticated way and if
you use um good denoising method that
will help the support
identification, you will need some
sparity but also model validation can
help. We found the softspace pursuit to
be better to deal with because it's
concretely telling how many terms and so
on. And then this is accompanied by the
model selection using time evolution
error, multi-time evolution error, cross
validation as well as trimming. These
are all fundamentally
uh given by the numerical PD. the idea
of numerical PDEs um and using that
we're trying to validate uh the model uh
the select coefficient identification is
always done by the le square fit but
from the weak ident we learned that you
can even look at the high dynamic region
to even improve the coefficient and also
for ident you find the meaningful data
to fit it then your coefficient recovery
can be even improved
Now in this sense I do want to be clear
about this. So one thing I can say is
that why do I talk about ident robust
ident um well while I have this method
right so for example if somebody ask me
right now say I don't care about any of
this give me one method I just want to
try it then I would say use weak ident
okay so weak ident is most stable so I
will do that even then why do I talk
about ident or robust ident the reason
is the ident and robust ident can handle
any terms any terms any boundary
condition but in order to take advantage
of the weak ident or for ident the data
should have a periodic boundary
condition. So what we do is that rather
than changing the boundary condition we
pad it we pad and then so that we don't
lose information but we make this
periodic. We mentioned this in the paper
and also in order to take advantage of
the weak form you have a certain form
that you needs to we needs to have lot
of the equation people are interested KS
equation KDV and all of these things is
in this form. So yes, so if you have you
are looking for these things, you look
uh you can use weak ident. However, if
you want to be really free, you want to
really give any kind of method, I still
think the ident and robust ident, we can
try to improve this so that we can
handle any problem.
One last thing I want to briefly mention
is that up to here all of the equation
that I'm mentioning is about finding one
equation given one set of data one
equation but who says right what if the
equation itself is changing right so I
want to talk about varying coefficient
so in the original ident paper that we
also had that and then we also have a
group SP so let me
explain so variable coefficient of
differential equation looks like this.
You have a certain equation at the
beginning maybe it start out with a
diffusion equation but then it suddenly
change to transport equation it includes
that because we are allowing the
coefficients to change from zero to non
zero or non zero to zero and things like
this. So how do we model this? One of
the classical method to use is finite
element. So we give an element. So we
give an element. So this coefficient you
used to be a constant now becomes a
finite element all of the elements. So
now you can
imagine this feature matrix gets
significantly fatter right it used to be
one column now this one column is
representing one element. So for each
element you need to have a copy of
yourself. So you have a constant you
have l number of bases then you will be
expand to l number and you have u then u
will be expanded ux will be expanded. So
everything is going to be expand by the
number of your basis function that is
represented by l. But how do you do it?
But this whole chunk is the same
anyways. So we use a group lass. So
using this as one
chunk. Now here what did what we use is
that we use group lo but we know that's
not enough. So how do we uh did the
model selection the model selection is
added by increasing the number of basis
function. Okay like
this have a linear system it needs to be
den nois in a proper way but this one
was the initial ident. So we used a
moving average le square and we use a
support identification using the group
lasso but you improve this by using what
is called base
expansion in the numerical PTE if you
increase the number of bases function
your approximation should get more
accurate so that's the idea if you
increase the number of L does it get
closer to the given data that is how we
pick now how do we move forward from
this because we did SP the subspace
pursue. Now we have group subspace
pursue. So we use the same basis
function the base element and then we
use successive denoising STD because
this is after robos
ident. Now among the group SV we still
have to have a model selection in this
case we use a reduction in residual. So
same linear system how do we uh set up a
linear system in a good way and then how
do we use the sparsity and the model
selection group projected SP is actually
different from block subspace pursue
because we are actually projecting to
the projected space. So that is the
difference. So this is measured in
detail. So from the feature matrix so
just to illustrate the each feature
matrix is fatter because for each
element that you need to have that many
uh columns. So each element is fatter.
You put this into sp k is equal to one k
is equal to 2 and so on and so forth.
And then we find the one which gives you
the first big drop. So that's how we
find it and then you do the le
square. So this is the trajectory. This
is one given image given uh feature that
where the coefficient is changing from
one to another. So this is true
coefficient for uxx and this is true
coefficient
ux and then if you use a group sp so
this is no noise case. This is the error
error of the coefficient. Okay. So
there's some fluctuation but they're
pretty good. If you add the noise then
it does find this find the coefficient
but at the end there are some uh places
that which is not accurate as well
because identity self is very difficult
and we're doing a finite difference um
and we're allowing many more uh
parameter to be chosen because of the
element these problems are very
difficult so there's not exactly same
work in this direction however we sort
of took something similar to compare.
So what we found out is that as the
noise is increasing as noise level is
increasing then it starts to find more
unnecessary terms but if you use a group
SB that still even if it goes to like 6%
and so on that it still identifies the
correct term the correct term meaning
that some term may be zero or not zero
at some point but including that line if
there's any nonzero term in the time
evol solution that this will be
identified. This is the size of the
dictionary. This is difficult to do have
a
diffic dictionary. So the dictionary one
is only using 35 terms, 56 term and 330
terms but consistently group SP will be
able to identify the correct term.
Um okay so um to summarize um given a
single set of time dependent noisy data
identifying an underlying equation is
very difficult problem. However, if you
use a numerical approximation in a
clever way, a lot of numerical
techniques can
um contribute to this this work and I
think you can benefit from it. And the
sparsity needs to be
um sparsity needs to be handled with
care. Um and a lot of the coefficient
recovery has been done by le square but
which can be also uh improved as well.
So um yes so that's all I want to say.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much
for the wonderful talk. Uh Professor
Kang um let's have a Q&A session. Um
there are bunch of questions in in chat
room. Not sure you can um see that or
not. Um the starting with the
Rosel he asked why do we not check the
error at the intermediate time. So I
think he was asking his questions in the
beginning before you explain about the
multi-shooting um stuff. Yeah, if you
can handle that question.
Yes, thank you for the question. Yes,
you can check intermediate time. So
you're absolutely right. So from the
beginning at the end at the beginning
the inident the reason why we check at
the end is because to give enough chance
for the error to grow. So if there's a
wrong term that we wanted this to grow,
that's why we give the full benefit to
check at the end. But as I showed you
for the multi-shooting case, you can do
it in in the middle so that you can sum
this to kind of show the difference. I
hope that answered this question.
Okay, thank you. Oh 3D. So how about 3D
PDS? Oh yeah, even to be honest even 2D
is very difficult especially when you go
to the varying coefficient is very
difficult. um 3D extension I do think it
is possible to do but if it is but if
you go to the varying coefficient it
gets much more difficult but in um it
depends on the problem if the equation
is so so for
example let's say data is given but data
is given in like 3D PTE but the data
itself is so boring then you may get a
very simple
result but if the data itself is rich
enough to handle all this then they will
try to find something. So I would say
the can can it scale to 3D? Yes,
probably there are some computational
cost because of the size of the uh
dictionary but we are introducing many
method to stabilize it. So I do believe
the 3D should work uh but it depends on
the data. The data needs to be given
with enough uh information. Yes, the
multivariable. Yes, it's the same qu
same question. I hope I answer your
question. Um, thank you. Yeah, thank
you. Awesome. Okay, next question is by
Looney. Yeah, the periodic petting. Ah,
well, can we state the uh question
first? So that because it's recorded and
the YouTube um people will appreciate
it. So the previous question was how
about 3D PD or multivariable PD. So
that's how I answered it. Now the next
question is that I wonder how did you
adjust the periodic padding if the
original field boundary condition is
non-periodic that's
corre very very important question uh
using any value of a pitting introduced
a false gradient between one of the
boundary petting yes that's right so
this is a very good question so what we
did was that we we made a copy and cut
it in half and then we flipped it right
so we we did flip but you're right the
derivative around the boundary may not
be um as accurate as the other so it is
true uh but we didn't see too much of
this effect again I think this will
depend on the data meaning the boundary
information is so heavy then this will
but most of the dynamic is happening in
the main domain then this effect will be
uh minimized in a way so but yes there
there will some the the loss in the
information. Awesome. Okay, next one is
Amit. Actually, Amit, do you want to
unmute and ask um directly? Uh sure. U
so very nice talk. Thank you for
summarizing all of these methods. Uh we
are trying to learn PDS uh
three-dimensional PDS for uh systems
like we want to train or discover
meoscale continuum models from atomistic
data. So everything is in 3D and the
general assumption when we look at all
the PDs that are out there the general
assumption is that only either the first
order time derivative or the second
order time derivative is enough to
capture the time evolution.
But um I wonder if you can tell us
something about PDS where you have let's
say first and second order time
derivatives present or if possible
higher order time derivatives present
and situations where the time derivative
is coupled with spatial derivatives.
Yes, this is a very very good question.
Um so yes we did um suffer um with this
in a way. So it's not so because of the
initial motivation that we had was to
see the dynamic. So we didn't really
uh look into too much in terms of UT and
UTT or things like that. So we didn't
really uh look into that part very
carefully. However, some of the weak
form models that they do have UT and UTT
in it. So it's matter of the column. So
what you want to anchor against and then
you can put any column any kind of
feature that you want. So you can put
UTT in it, you can you put UTUX in it
and so on. But what you get at the end
is at the end is a le square. So how
well do you fit the data is what it what
it means uh what will give you the
result. Did I answer your question?
Sure. I think um that's what we were
trying to do. But I I wanted to see if
there are other ways to formulate the
problem. But anyway, I think I think
your I think your suggestion is good.
The other problem is this is related to
what FA had asked about the 3D systems
is that um everything looks nice well
relatively nice when you handle 1D
systems. The moment you go to 3D systems
at least for our case we are finding
that the matrices are severely ill
conditioned in the sense ill conditioned
and because we we have a large
dictionary they are rank deficient. So
we have looked at close to 20 different
or maybe more than that different sparse
solvers and believe me the results are
all over the place. Yes. So the question
then is how do we for severely ill
conditioned or rank deficient linear
systems
um it's not it doesn't seem
straightforward to um come up with a
with a solution like a discover a PD and
it
yes you're absolutely right so this is
the reason why we've been using SP is
because we're the SP the idea is that
just find the one best one but the
softspace pursue basically is the least
residual. So you look for one column one
column that which gives you the least
residual two column which give you least
residual. So we this is the reason why
we put k is equal to 1 k is equal to k
is equal to 3 and k is equal to 4 and we
list all of this and then this is why we
introduce trimming and so on because
it's difficult. You're absolutely right.
So if you use like a different type of
sparity in a different way, it's going
to be all over the place. And this is
what we observe also when we use like a
lasso at the beginning. So this is why
we accompany with time evolution error,
multi-time evolution error. All of this
is introduced for this reason. So I
completely understand where you're
coming from. So this is the reason why
we were just doing one by one concretely
and then uh suggest a good way to pick
among that. So that is the reason. Did I
answer your question? Yeah. Thank you so
much. appreciate it. It's a hard problem
to begin with, so I understand. Okay,
got it. Okay, thank you. Uh David, do
you want to unmute and ask question?
Yeah, guess not. Um very nice talk. Hey,
always impressed with the what what what
the results are here. Um so I I have a a
question about the you're using lasso
and uh so one of the things that uh when
we looked at lasso and um some other
methods of that type uh a while ago one
of the things that came up is that there
seemed to be some issues in satisfying
like isometry conditions and I was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
that that if it if it was if it was
working for you or it seemed like when
we were using those methods they weren't
working very well well at all and it was
it seemed like that was the source a bit
and so I was just curious if you had uh
we hadn't looked at in a while so I was
curious if you'd looked at it and seen
anything. Yeah, thank you for this
question. Yes. So um in that paper that
when we were looking into it so what it
boils down to it actually like um maybe
I didn't emphasize this enough the what
it boils down to is the co coherence of
it. So let's say we have let's say 330
uh matrix right that you have each
column they are all coordinated to each
other then any type of loss so it's not
going to work well so it needs the
column needs to be independent enough
then you have a chance so now SP is it
better well in SP that you may get
random things right like if you have one
or two because if they are correlated
you might pick one versus the other but
at least in SP they will give you the
least residual one but I'm not saying
it's perfect either but yes the one
thing that I didn't mention too much is
the coherence among the the columns does
affect the result of lasso or L1
minimization so that is the difficult
part
yeah I hope I answer in some way
okay well thank you thank you so much um
is there any other questions
That's all we have seen so
far.
Um, if not, let's thank our uh speaker
uh for the wonderful presentations and
the great uh Q&A sessions. Thank you so
much everybody. Thank you for coming to
my talk. I really appreciate it. It is
nice to see a lot of people that I know.
Thanks. Awesome. Awesome. Bye. Thank
you.